you claimed infinite banking concept was
a scam and actually got quite pissed off
about it I um do not agree with that in
certain points that you made in that
um video and I have set up a policy for
my son when he was one years old he's
five now it has a five hundred thousand
dollar face value we pay five thousand
three hundred seventy three dollars a
year for 13 years and it's paid up at
that point so you claim that uh the cash
value dies with you and you only get um
to face value uh paid out that's true
that is well it's not true if you
reinvest the dividends back into the
policy dividend reinvestment is not cash
value
dividend reinvestment is because you
have a mutual company and the
policyholders are the owners of the
company and so the profits from the
company come to the policyholder